[Music]
don't be a fake
don't be a flake don't run away from
your feelings babe don't be afraid don't
be ashamed don't hesitate to say hey
babe
hey babe hey babe hey
[Music]
hey babe how you doing sal i'm good
toots how are you i haven't seen you in
a while wait i gotta sound like sal
is more animated and big and okay okay
here we go one two three
hey babe how you doing sal i'm good
what's going on with you chrissy d i
haven't seen you i've been in la and now
you're out here and
i'm out here different yeah a little bit
different i got a lot of stuff going on
you know i dyed my hair i'm trying to
fit up trying to be an
la guy getting in the movie base wow and
it looks good and it sounds like you've
gained weight i gained a ton of weight
i'm doing it for a new role
wow lumpy and plumpy that's yeah hi
i no it's not sal volcano it's andrew
santino
hey hey from bad friends is co-hosting
today uh hey babe today
thank you so much for coming on of
course buddy and you came out and you're
here
and you and i first of all yesterday
we went to a california angels game with
uh my father yep tony d with the pops
and you bought us all a bag of peanuts
my dad as soon as you left he said i
appreciate him buying me those bag of
peanuts but he made me feel like an
elephant
so what happened well that's because i
was throwing him at his face i wanted
him to catch it you know because when
you do it with the elephants you can
throw it at them and they'll catch you
they catch with the tree so did i hit
your dad with a couple dozen peanuts yes
yes but he could have just opened his
mouth once and caught one peanut in his
mouth but he didn't do it
and of course i just want to give a
shout out real quick to tom brady and
tampa buccaneers and i would be remiss
if i didn't mention the kansas city
chiefs hell of a game they played shout
out patrick holmes
great kid listen i got stand up dates
coming okay
chrisdcomedy.com we just put a big one
on sale today
october 23rd the fox theater foxwoods
connecticut it's my first big theater
thousand seater baby so go to
christycomedy.com
get those tickets for the october 23rd
foxwoods date
right now today to the end of today if
you use the pre-sale code
fox5 pre-sale code fox5 you can get
tickets early they're selling very
quickly
october 23rd and then we got providence
in july
eatontown new jersey in august nashville
in october we got
september dates november we're in boston
we're all over the place
chrisdcomedy.com thank you so much
i had a great time i had so much fun i
mean how much fun do we have there was
so much there was if you guys are you
know in the california area the
california angels
anaheim angels of la whatever their team
name is now
yeah they we went into that game they
didn't ask us for a vax car they don't
do a temp check
they barely even cared if your mass was
up and down as long as you were eating
or drinking
we felt safe yeah we felt good and we
actually
enjoyed the game and it felt for me such
a relief to just go back to nor
i felt normal somewhat normal well and
by the way you don't have to wear the
mask if you're eating and drinking which
no offense you know you were going to do
the whole time
yeah yeah could you imagine can we can
we do a countdown to the food let's do a
countdown of the total food of the of us
three what we had
so we went through a couple of beers a
diet coke we had two modelos
two models you had a pretzel pretzel
with cheese pops out of pretzel without
cheese two bags of nachos two bags
we had one he had one yeah i had a brat
you had a full pizza two pepperoni
pizzas
pizza peppa pig pizza and then yeah and
then you also went back for seconds
what did i get again you know what you
got i forgot oh chicken fingers chicken
fingers and french fries
elementary school lunch yes for like a
whole school of kids like 85 kids but
here's the thing
is i because i was like oh andrew's
eating i can eat even though even though
he's thinner than me i'm like oh
auntie's eating i can eat and then by
the time i finish my second round of
food
i i said to andrew's like what else did
you eat today he's like all i've had is
a can of tuna so far and i was like oh
my god
i walked into the game already at 2 000
calories no i said
i said i had i had eggs for breakfast
and then i had two eggs
i had two eggs with a piece of sausage
and then and then i had a sausage
yes and then i had and then i had a cup
of tuna uh while i was golfing but a cup
of tuna no mayo nothing just tuna right
out of the can bear
yeah well they put they put onions in it
i like it with onions because i really
want to stank it up
some bad news for you oh okay
as far as because here's the thing are
my levels going to be all messed up
what's going on yup
bad news for you have you seen a
documentary called see spiricy look
are the fish eating plastic and i'm
eating the plastic fish
yes fine yes fine yes fine i got the vac
six times already yeah i kept going back
thank you
sir you already had two i said i want
two more what double down baby
you're also contributing to a uh high
seas
international slave trade where a fish a
slave a fish slave trade yep
fish slavery so so not only are you
eating plastic but
you are a slave master so okay i'm a
fish slave master though you're a fish
slave master but
but by the way the fish that i eat
they're all white so i'm okay with it
let me
tell you this too and i'm sure people
have told you this and i'm sure fans
obviously all the fans know who andrew
santino is but
but no they do but if you don't here's
the thing
dude why are we not pitching why are we
not pitching
the vincent van gogh movie with you as
the star 100 i'm willing to cut off my
ear and i'm willing to cut off my ear to
do it 100
i would do i would do it for the film
they'd say oh that's crazy we'll just do
cgi
we'll no i'm going to cut off my ear if
i get the roll for van gogh i'm slicing
it off slicing it right off putting it
in a box and i'm sending it to
the what did he do he sent it to the it
was it his
ex-wife is that what it was i don't know
he
what because he cause he cut off i
remember like he was this is at the end
of his life when he was losing his mind
right
and he cut off his ear but he put it in
a box if i remember yeah he mutilated
with a razor after
with his friend paul gagin yeah but i'll
play paul gagin okay ready
yeah then you cut your ear off right in
front of me yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
here
and it goes something like this uh uh no
she she said she said i love you
and then she left me so i'm cutting off
my ear no no no no vincent do not cut
off your i'm
cutting off my ear no but you have how
else is she going to hear how i feel
she's never going to listen to me so i'm
sending her my ear no no no no no
i'm doing it no no no no
can you imagine he's just got a pen and
paper he's like just do this i'm like
vince vincent what
no he yeah so look at this it says it's
the lobe it says
accept it but i don't want to believe
that i want to believe it was the whole
earth
but apparently there was the rumor that
he sent it to somebody and i don't know
if that's ever going to be a true thing
well you know what's very interesting
about vincent van gogh first of all i'm
trying i tried to get ticky wikis
to take uh uh jasmine while i was here
while we're here in la and my and my
daughter and the whole family to go to
the vincent van gogh exhibit in los
angeles been there
you bet you did it yep i couldn't get
tickets wait did it oh was it open
during during dronies yeah it's well i
think it's been open
it's like a vincent van gogh experience
in a fit of dementia van gogh threatened
his friend with a knife before turning
on himself mutilating his earlobe
afterward he allegedly wrapped up the
ear and gave it to a prostitute
that's so much cooler i thought he said
it to a girl he's in love with yeah the
story that they told us probably in
school you know what i mean like an art
history class they're like and it was to
the love of his life yeah
meanwhile it's some haggard pros
one-legged prostitutes yeah
just yeah he's like he's like here's
your tip here's your tip and she's like
if i needed one of these
yeah just get to the ear so but you know
what's interesting
so about van gogh is he wasn't famous
at all yeah no not nobody had heard of
him at all yeah he's one of those
years after he was one of these
posthumous fame guys they say that
there's a lot of guys from that
generation actually they're only
posthumously famous who else is
posthumously
yeah look up artists that are
approximately famous no no beethoven was
very famous while he was
i thought mozart was really famous and
beethoven wasn't beethoven also had
erasures well beethoven wasn't famous
until his latter half of his career
right when he was younger some of these
guys got popular when they were young
but look at that vermeer by the way
johannes vermeer if you've never seen
the movie
um uh tim's vermeer do you know what
this is no
do you know what this is pimp what's oh
my god homeless pimp didn't know what it
was
uh tim's vermeer is one of the greatest
films i've ever seen it was produced by
um
uh uh a pen and teller what's his name
penn gillette penn jillette yeah okay so
this is amazing this is honestly a
genuinely brilliant story if you've
never seen this movie so that gentleman
right there
who's quite a genius in his own regard
yes he said
he realized that there's there was
mathematical equations to how vermeer
used to paint right that they really
just used math to paint and and light
refraction
okay right so how a light would refract
an image through a stained glass window
and it would flip the image upside down
right is literally how he learned how to
paint so the rumor is this guy thinks he
cracked a code that vermeer
literally wouldn't paint freehand he was
stenciling from light he was just using
an image that was projected from light
almost like you'd almost like how
cartoonists do on um
lithography and this was in the 1600s
yeah dude so
this movie essentially sets out for this
gentleman to
in so many ways prove that he could
paint a vermeer in the
using the same process that he believes
he used and and for me and this is a
documentary yeah it's incredible and can
i tell you something
the painting that tim makes looks
identical to a vermeer well look and
this guy's never painted his it'd be you
and me
stick figure boys trying to paint a real
and it's so crazy that you brought that
up that vermeer thing you brought
brought that up because look at that
picture that fourth picture
sal has that up in our studio and
now we have the hay babe sign but when
we first started really that picture
with his face in it a vermeer painting
dude you are vermeer
i thought you were van gogh your vermeer
could be all of them
this by the way that's you know what
that painting is called that one that
vermeer
take a guess look at the painting and
see what you think that's cool one two
th the fourth one i would say that
is called well it's not called the sound
volcano wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait the fifth one the the one that
the mouse is on or the one to the left
of that the one
which one are you talking about i'm
talking about that one right that's the
most recognizable one right there yeah
this is the one sal's face was in
okay but don't give it away don't show
the name is that a picture what is it
arabian nights what is it called
[Laughter]
god's call girl goes to the club to duck
club d.a
to do duck club girl goes to the club
it's called cardi b show him show him
the name of the painting this is what
his name is
painting look look what it's called
jonathan vermeel style and technique
should show you the name of it right
below what's the name look girl with a
pearl earring that's it
very on the nose that's it girl with the
pearl earring
it used to be called girl with a pearl
necklace but his friends were like
you can't yeah he said it searched too
much on the internet yeah
for some reason vermeer knew that what
was going to happen in the future so he
took it away but anyway this dude
um in that movie i will i'm going to end
talking about it but
it blew my mind because he's never
painted a day in his life it's not like
you're talking about somebody who had
experience painting and then
no this dude has zero experience in the
world he just thought
he cracked the science of it right and
you should you absolutely should watch
it so you're saying that vermeer
knew this back then and you like he was
painting with math in his head but
didn't know how to explain it and
articulate it to people i think
well the rumor would be or the
speculation is alien
it was a secret that he didn't want to
tell anybody that was his way that he
painted
he just he literally just the light of
he would use
images reflect refracted on light
through the and i can't
wait to come up that he was looking at a
girl with a pearl earring in other words
in real life in real time
what he would do is he could take
they'll explain in the documentary so i
don't want to i don't want to give
anything away but this is awesome i
don't want to give
i don't want to give anything away but
essentially he found a way to take
images or things that you that he's seen
in the real world
and have them this is a good thing to
watch with the ladies
with with those with my legs for the
ladies yeah this is great
with jasmine this is because she loves
painting this should be good to watch
do you know what do you know what's one
thing i saw that was
mind-blowing and i don't remember the
name of the documentary but it was a
real thing
it was about people who get struck by
lightning or people who have
massive injuries to their brain than the
talents that they wake up with oh yeah i
saw
two stories that blew my mind blew my
balls off we say that a lot on this box
blew my balls off one guy got struck by
lightning
and then woke up and could speak fluent
spanish french and also
languages that haven't existed for a
thousand years fluently
just in his brain and this guy was like
a construction worker from cleveland
then i saw another guy i want to get i
want i want to get struck by like
a brain tumor had a brain tumor had a
stroke
and all these things gets up all of a
sudden can paint
start is painting all day every day
never even said he couldn't even draw a
stick figure
painting unbelievable paintings doing it
and then
stopping looking at it and then painting
another beautiful painting over the
painting and he couldn't stop painting i
think i saw that well there was the
brain is fascinating
what is it called marwyn call do you
know what marwin call is steve carell
did a rendition of this movie it was
originally a documentary about a guy
that's it right there
steve seacrest in a movie called welcome
to marwan but marwyn call the original
is incredible it's a documentary about a
guy who was beat up
who got traumatic brain injuries from
from getting into it he got jumped
yeah and he started to um paint and
create these little
war scenes like these little figurines
and it's on
dude it's more beautiful than i can
explain never did any of this before
never never so is that a key to
unlocking creativity
on stage should pimp just start kicking
me in the head well you
you might because you're so far gone
from being an intelligent person
this might just get you back to normal
got it so if you get hit in the head you
might just get
to square one roy cleveland sullivan a
park ranger in shenandoah national park
virginia which pimp has done mushrooms
at
was hit by lightning not once but seven
times during his life
to this day sullivan holds the record of
being hit by lightning more times than
any other human being in history
so that's like he went looking for it
looking for it or there's something
that's attracting lightning in his body
stay inside right don't be he's outside
every time it's like
oh it's raining i got to go put the
covers on the cushions on the on the
deck chairs just like roy
yeah stay inside he gets vaccinated he
never gets struck by lightning again
[Laughter]
he's got to be gone right now you know
what's that microchip he's got to be
dead he got sick he's
no chance that he survived seven
lightning strikes he was he was dead on
the day of the year we were born 1983.
no i'm 84.
oh you are at 84. oh here's something
fun that we did
pissed off my buddy we looked up um look
up uh your birthday and your birth date
like your year and look up number one
song on
your birthday let's just start with
andrew go ahead october 16th
1983. what was the number one song i
think what do you mean capricorn i think
it was man-eater by daryl hall and john
no no no no i'm sorry oh no it'll it'll
say here look at this number one song on
october
click on that what was the number one
song on it the safety dance the
the safety dance well that's on october
wait wait wait scroll down because it
goes down when we did it it said
oh total eclipse of the heart is the day
before my birthday all right so we'll
come on
song now do august 26th august 26
1984. oh yeah do songs singular not
plural that's number one
song
there's something man in your
neighborhood pimp what's yours god you
that's a good dude that's a good one
what's yours february 13
92.
have you ever seen a guy who's sexier in
corduroy pants than the homeless pimp
you know what's so funny because i don't
look down i'm looking at his beautiful
eyes i didn't even notice he was wearing
those stunning pants well his eye his
eyes are so beautiful that i've asked
him to wear his glasses all the time
while he's in my house because you don't
want to worry about it i got it i got it
i got it yes you don't want her to come
down and go what are you guys doing
you're chatting
chatting we're just chatting again yeah
um
you know what's crazy too about
ghostbusters timeout real fast
those pants beautiful color they remind
me of the spicy brown mustard
at that game and tampa tony and i they
didn't have any ketchup
he wanted some ketchup and let me say
this to california angels if this is
something that you're trying to do just
to mess with us
it worked yeah cause we looked forever
for ketchup
no one none of the stanch none of the
stations had ketchup which by the way as
a chicago guy we can't put ketchup on
our hot dogs we have to put mustard
but tampa tea he can do what he wants
yeah and he didn't get the
he didn't get the ketchup that he wanted
the ketchup that he wanted and you know
disappointed me
and what a catchy name for a franchise
the los angeles angels of anaheim it's
actually
worked so great the california angels of
los angeles anaheim
southern california yes dt 2024
that's what they're called yes presented
by lexus and what did we say and ballets
and valleys because you had a good point
you said it's going to get to the point
where sports teams this is a
it's actually a mind-blowing thing that
andrew said last night during the game
sports teams it's going to get to the
point where it's not the
you know new york knicks it's the it's
the you know
it's amazing the amazon knicks or it's
you know
right honda right racket you know like
well because you look at soccer
my buddy's really into soccer and he i
try to keep up a little bit with him
dude they they their their jerseys are
just they look like good nascar cars
it's annoying well it's not a jersey
anymore because i was saying uh tampa t
was wearing like a
sexy old new um yankees jersey and i was
like
right the pinstripes it just is so cool
yes baseball jerseys are so cool looking
right and you're like if they start
putting stuff all over these
right i don't i'll never buy them
anymore yeah me either you don't want
your little kid walking around like
it's it's like target you know it's like
that's presented by target or what about
or what about uh eventually some of
these companies are gonna you know just
like companies that we don't want like
viagra i'm gonna have my daughter in a
viagra jersey do you mean do you do you
really not want that all right that's
true
well i don't need it yet but we are
getting close fingers crossed
polo here's here's a little sports fact
polo first appeared in persia which is
now modern-day
iran iran iran please say it correctly
sorry
okay sorry uh around 2 500 years ago
making it the oldest known team sport
and one for the rich and wealthy as team
members have had to have their own horse
have you ever played polo oh my god no i
actually hate i'm against riding horses
i've never been on a horse somewhere i
went on a horse one time and it was like
got annoyed and tried to get me off and
i was like we don't belong on these
things yeah it doesn't like
they don't want us on its back and then
you hit it in its ass i don't like that
why are you hitting it i never
understood this about like they're still
we were in new orleans and their cops on
horses you know
yeah why get a car get a car get a car
you know
there's there's 300 horses inside the
car and
you just have one i don't understand i
don't have this in chicago when you go
to chicago remember the cop in a box
there was a little cop driving around
in in i saw this with my own eyes in
broad daylight
my friends cop in a box driving around
giving tickets yeah i was 16 17 years
old pushed over the cop in the box
and then started running away and you
just see the top of the box legs
like a fat baby just can't roll over
just pushed it over and that you know
it's before cell phones or
so it's like we got away with that yeah
but the cop in the box was the stupidest
thing
i've ever seen in my entire life pimp
you might even be too young for copper
box you ever see cop in the box
you're not google cop in the box nypd
you're 92.
yeah that was probably right around the
time that it was idiots used to drive
around
it was so stupid yeah so stupid look at
them look at how dumb stupid that is
they would
really oh they just look they look it's
that one right there i mean it's so
dumb we would you could push them over
they weighed like 200 pounds
we pushed one over with an active duty
police officer in it
all that is is a front one wheel golf
cart that's all they did and they put a
couple of doors on it that's awesome
the horses are it's such a stupid thing
it's it's all these things for just
posturing so well yeah but that's my
rule about animals i never because i
went to the i went to the calgary
stampede one time to shoot the show
and they made us interview bull riders
and bull fighters and all that stuff and
clap
rodeo clowns and i didn't like it
because i
do you know what they do to the bulls do
you guys know they they put a rope
around there
and they tug on it and they kick it
really yeah dude i saw it firsthand i
didn't like it
look i'm not one of these animal rights
activists but i got to tell you my rule
with animals is
you eat it or you leave it alone
i don't know this is torture why are you
torturing it you want to kill the animal
and you eat it
for protein eat it leave it alone or
have sex with it there's a group of
people that want to have sex with it i'm
just i'm not your cat
i'm not into the last one okay i'm not
into the last one what about zoos
huh you like zoos i hate zeus i hate
zoos i thought he said what about jews
real quick by the way
but you know how i feel about them i
love them
right in the camera ready to go uh know
about zeus yeah do you like zoos that's
a very good
question i hate zeus so when i was a kid
actually and still in chicago lincoln
park zoo is in the center of the city
it's a free zoo
still one of the only like free zoos
completely free you can walk in and out
and as a kid i i remember kind of like
being a little fascinated that like my
mom could walk me to a zoo because we
used to live not that far from this
awesome
yeah because the part lincoln park is
huge but then i got older
and and as you start to like grow real
eyeballs you look at how
sad the oh they're so sad dude yeah
they're in prison they're
nothing yeah they didn't do anything
yeah they didn't do anything
they got they got so no i'm totally
against zoos i don't like them i think
these
look again animals kill them and eat
them so we can use them for protein
because
i like eating meat or leave them alone
you need to stay jacked
yeah and i need to stay gay yeah i just
feel like kill them and eat them or leak
leave them alone chicago
says animals are safe and accounted for
after rumors that someone escaped by the
way this is like the 15th time this has
happened
you can look it up they have escaped
lincoln park too so many times because
kids would break into the park and then
break open you know the barriers
hilarious to let them out well
and realize it's all that just by bars
and stuff up and down clark street
and it's not like this is not like bs
animals you talk about they would let
out like bears and tigers whatever they
just opened animals in there real
animals yeah just open the cages let
them out dude you want to know what's
one of the sickest things i've ever seen
i just finished watching it guys can you
stop and i just and i just finished
watching it
was it was called my octopus teacher uh
on netflix did you see this no but you
know what we've been told to watch it
and
i saw the preview broke my soul because
the octopus remembers him no that
remembers him but dude no
no but what's crazy about it is and they
don't say that
they say this without saying this this
man fell
in love with an octopus what are you
talking about willis no no no when you
watch this documentary the way he's
talking about it
the chemicals in his brain shift the
chemicals in his brain shifted
and he now fell in love with a female
octopus
that is what happened without when you
i'm like he's talking about the female
octopus
as if it's a lover and then he would go
down at night and just he was like i
love when he was just the octopus and i
when the cameras were off
and i would feel her suction cups and i
could really feel i said this guy now i
don't want to watch it he's having sex
with the octopus now i don't want to
watch it
at the beginning i thought it was a
beautiful friendship and a relationship
between like the the you know this this
a man and animal kind of no this is this
is this is pervert stuff this is pervert
stuff it proves that
even in the animal world you can't
nobody can have a platonic relationship
between a male and a female by the way
it's going to come out in four or five
years all over the internet this guy's
been doing this to a lot of octopi a lot
of octopus yeah it's not his first one
dude
they're gonna clip them on twitter if
you guys have a chance to watch it watch
my octopus teacher on netflix because
it what first of all that part to me was
mind-blowing i was like this is crazy
and and i don't even think it was creepy
or weird i'm like wow this guy's
chemicals are just attaching itself to
this octopus it
kind of just shows you like love is like
a chemical it
yeah because he was going through a lot
in his life but you know what was really
sick
the octopus this is a animal that
doesn't make sense
it's otherworldly yeah it has it's alien
that's an alien
it's an alien dude it knows how to it
it's well the only one of the only
animals that's been observed in the wild
it uses logic and reasoning to protect
itself
so when sharks come by it gathers up a
hundred or 200 seashells and makes a
fort
around itself it plays hide and seek it
will put
it will put leaves and kelp over itself
and then look and come back
the fish schools of fish will come by
and it goes out and plays with them
they have three hearts and blue blood
yes they squirt ink to deter predators
i've seen that and boneless which is so
cool they can just
they can make themselves into almost
nothing
i'm spineless we know that's trophy yeah
by the way now now bring up a video of a
sushi chef uh cutting apart an octopus
i'd love to see that as well
because i saw one this morning just
listen have you ever eaten octopus i i
do it's delicious
it's delicious it's delicious so so has
this guy ever eaten octopi
yeah i no like he's saying now no he's
saying now know that he won't eat
octopus because he observed how smart
there i'm this way with pigs dude
once i saw a documentary and how smart
you're going to be bacon i mean bacon
man
really i can't eat it so that means the
meat that i eat i think the animals are
dumb
that's what i'm saying house dumb
chicken dum
eat them turkey eat them dumb um
what else do you mean and then birds
like like have you ever had pheasant or
i've done
i've never i've never had pheasant only
because the word pheasant is real
yeah it's pheasant i can't think of what
about deer deer smart animal never had a
deer
you've never had never had deer venison
never had venison because it's baby deer
i love baby deer venison
i've never had venison because i i can't
think of the fact that it's a baby deer
because i heard that
i heard that with baby deer when you're
eating venison they never even let the
deer's feet touch the floor
is that true just hang them up hang them
up so i have noises
have you ever had fog now you're talking
to me like my dad
what did you just call me have you ever
had fog [ __ ] what are you calling me a
fuckwall
you get over here no what's pagua fagwa
duck liver it's fatty duck liver
oh it's delicious i'd like to take a
bite out of your liver after the
drinking we did last night my god
i mean that's very fatty right now um no
i've never had it
see that's the thing is i cause people
are like oh if you knew how your food
was being processed or made
yeah you wouldn't want to eat it but i
don't think that's true i know what
count i know cows eat other cows
you just you don't you have no respect
for cows i don't think i have any
respect for cows that's what it is but
you respect pigs ironically you know
go to india cows cow is sacred sacred
and and you don't care at all and i
don't care at all
maybe because i am a pig i don't know
but if you're living in india and you're
a muslim
you don't need cow or pig so what do you
eat just veggies
i don't know i mean surely chicken and
turkey fries i would think if the most
muslims don't even don't eat swine right
isn't that true
why aren't they all they should ever
don't misquote me because i'm not smart
enough to know the difference catholics
eat everything except
we're not supposed to happen we don't
just eat islam prohibits eating a flesh
of swine yeah it's a sin right it's a
sin to do so but that's very interesting
that why would an entire religion say
you can't eat the flesh of this pig
well he could look it up but what i've
heard from friends was that uh
it's because swine at the time that this
thing kind of became a thing in the in
the
in the in in the religion was because of
the dirtiest animals on
they were like the filthiest animals on
earth but they're so smart well they
bathed in their own poop
in the poop after a while section is
prohibited because they have a cloven
hoof oh that's why
but don't chew and don't chew their cud
right can you go back
pimp to that video you just pulled up
how they make fog
so you see that they can't they can't
regurgitate it's cut being it's unclean
for you because it bathes and eats its
own
what do you mean they can't regurgitate
well look at it look at it just i just
said it right there sorry pimpy
yeah look and and a pig because it has a
cloven hoof and it's completely split
but it will not regurgitate it it's what
it's like what is its cut it's unclean
for you it's kid cud
i think it's kid cuddy i think it's one
of i love kevin i'll be eating pigs all
day
and all night yeah that's his good song
what's that hbo show it only got one or
two seasons but kid cudi was in it it
was incredible the new york show yeah
that new year i i
heard that show's coming back i love
that show what was it called was it
vinyl no no no no no no no
hold on don't do it hold on hold on it's
called um um
oh i see it it's like it was like it was
like an ensemble castle yes cuddy
this how to make it in america 2016. no
no what what year that wasn't 2000.
2010 it only got two seasons this show i
heard is coming back
really show it's fanta that's a show
yeah that's a show
that i would actually try to do whatever
i could to try to get on audition for
dude i've done this for a multitude of
shows it's only worked for me
putting it out to the universe worked
out for me um curb enthusiasm
and arrested development i really worked
hard to say i wanted to get on those
shows and i got on
the the one show well there's two shows
on the network i'm already on that i
begged
to be on and i couldn't get on either
was baskets because i wanted to be on
galvanic as a show
more than anything and just i said i'll
do it for free i'll i will pay i'll
drive myself
that's how bad i wanted to just be i
wanted to be in the background and why
they say no
they just cause he uses a lot of like
very very unknown or real i mean you
don't know anybody on that show except
for
there's a few people that have done a
few things but for the most part he
wanted to find people so to speak you
know martha kelly that's on there sure
she she was somewhat in the world but
like definitely not
in a known space right he wanted more
they said that they wanted
less recognizable people or less
familiar people and
and just kind of new talent which was he
did he found some incredible people
because he wanted to make it up to feel
like it was baker's field
and then the other show which is on
right now which is also my favorite i'm
promoting every show but the one i'm on
on fx
but what we do in the shadows i think is
one of the greatest shows i've ever seen
in my life right i've never seen it
that's what we do in the shadows
it's absolutely brilliant dude it was a
movie
and um jermaine clement of flight of the
concords did it
okay uh created with takawati it's a
comedy show what we do in the show it's
not just it's not a comedy it's a
it's the funniest dude it's a it's
basically about
vampires in modern day that live in
staten island
they truly live on staten island why
wouldn't you buy that show if i'm in the
room they're like
it's old world vampires from
transylvania that have been transported
into 2021
in staten island right now and they go
we live in staten island that's what
they say we're living in staten island
we're going to take over the world from
staten island dude it's
brilliant and matt berry is in it who i
think is like
i've bragged about him on every podcast
i've ever done i'm like boasting to meet
matt barry i just think he is
a literal genius let's get let's get i
mean let's find a way
barry is a genius i have one question
for you yeah what was uh cause we asked
chris and sal
what was the one time you were most
embarrassed that you bombed in front of
of a celebrity um babes
yep we are in the thick of 2020's ugly
sequel and guess what life can still be
stressful as f
yeah i mean if you're feeling that
existential dread whenever you have a
couple of minutes of downtime
you might be experiencing those scary
luckily our partners at sunday scaries
make the best f
and c we need products to turn those
wtfs into lols
forget about an old awkward date or that
time you responded to a server telling
you to enjoy your meal
with a good old youtube sunday scaries
is here to provide you the remedy to
make life not so scary their cbd
gummies are so perfect they're the
perfect product to help you kick back
and chill
the f out they even added vitamins b12
and d3 to get that extra boost of
vitamin goodness to give you the perfect
blend to make you more tolerable to
co-workers and friends
babe can i ask you a question yeah you
vegan no
sunday scaries even as vegan gummies
called vegan af
that are the guilt-free version of cbd
you've been kindly hunting
to help you forget about becky's
showboat ig account
don't get shook in 2021 get 20 percent
off
at sundayscaries.com and use the promo
code hey babe
20 off at scares.com with promo code hey
babe
it's 20 off at sundayscaries.com with
the promo code hey babe
thanks sunday scaries for making sundays
chill again
chris yeah can you please tell me if you
know of any place that i can go
if i want to get a little bit of
discreet counseling
off the top of my head the number one
place that i
i'm thinking of is betterhelp.com
well what's that i gotta go to some
office no which i gotta pay outrageous
prices nope
well i gotta wait two weeks to start it
nope you can do it from the comfort of
your own home
get a discreet licensed counselor
to hear whatever it is you want to talk
about
for a great price if you put in the
promo code hey babe
you actually get ten percent off the
first month ten percent off american
go to ten perce as far as i'm as far as
i know
i was told ten percent american money
wherever you could be in islamabad
pakistan
right you're still gonna get off ten
percent american for the first month by
going to better help
not health better help help calm
promo code hey babe h-e-y-b-a-b-e
10 off the first month it's just it's
the right thing to do
i can't believe i asked you that because
you had all the information i needed
sal a lot of times i'll see you doing
things
and i'll say why don't you just ask me
yeah and i'm happy that
on the podcast you decided to ask me
remember that time i was just putting a
straw into an orange and you were like
you should just pour yourself a glass of
juice
yes i should defer to you more often and
where do you think because
like i was just like you how many times
did you see me
putting the straw into the orange a how
did i learn
to start drinking orange juice
betterhelp.com
betterhelp.com is where i learned that
you don't have to do that it's just in
the commercial
do they stick the straw in the orange
juice you don't want to make sense
because we could all
use better help dot com
backslash hey babe for 10 off who
doesn't want 10
off the first month of anything i want
10 percent off everything they're
getting me spoiled
yeah better help is getting me spoiled
yeah i storm into a room now the first
thing i say is i want 10 percent off i
want to talk
where i am yeah if they come to back to
this show and they want to advertise
we love your fans so much they've been
they've been supporting betterhelp.com
hey babe so much we want to give you 20
off i'm going to say no it's going to
stay at 10.
that's right it just feels right he's
trying to take advantage
it just feels right betterhelp.com hey
babe
i mean i told a story on our show i
bombed in front of chris rock worse than
i've ever bombed in my entire life
like stand up yeah not even on stage
like in conversation oh no this was on
stage
it was even more embarrassing
conversation i can walk away from
because it's just sometimes it's weird
yeah
you take a swing and you i bombed so bad
in front of rock in the in the original
room
late night it's a comedy store mm-hmm
but and what it just and it was a full
zero like
you got a zero i mean for us for us
you know like you don't really bomb bomb
anymore but it was a late night
tuesday night it was one of the worst
sets you had in years and you have to be
in front of chris ross
and he didn't walk out of the room he
watched oh he sat in the bucket seats
and then i sat down next to him in the
bucket seat and then he literally goes
he like kind of waited for a minute a
couple of minutes and then he goes
good stuff and then he walked away and i
was like oh no that's
brutal especially because like brennan
had just introduced me
in the green room because chappelle was
there and like
you know i just but but it was because i
skipped my other spots and i when i go
when i used to go at least when this was
alive i would never bump
i would just wait until there was a hole
even if i missed my original spot
i would never slide people away because
i was like oh these guys are the late
night guys and they work hard just to
get these spots so
i would just keep waiting so i probably
waited till midnight or midnight 30 to
do it
and and by then the crowd is gone or
they're or they're so drunk they're
they're asleep and they're or they're
foreign sometimes the foreign people
don't know that they can leave
right in the comments where they just
show up and and they sit there all night
like this and they're just
don't they don't know because it's a
running show right it's
like we don't have to be yeah i don't
know when it's appropriate to leave the
show
and you know and so these nazis they
just keep getting drinks all night
because they don't know when to leave
no but it's one of those things where
like you you feel bad it's like the end
of the night and uh and
it was it just to work out it was to
work out brand new stuff well here's the
thing here's one
which is when that's when you do it
that's why chris wrong is there but
here's the thing
play that let's put that neil degrasse
tyson clip up here's the thing why
here's why lately i've been like
watching all this stuff about like
aliens in different dimensions where
it's like
a year ago i would have bombed in front
of chris rock and like my life was over
whatever but now
i just realized that none of it matters
because now neil degrasse tyson is
saying
that he did research with all the top
people in the field and this tick tock
he just
he just uh uh put up was mind-blowing to
me
how there's really only one or two
uh answers there's only one of two
answers of what we're doing here and
what what's going on
do you have a pimpy can you guys come
down the stairs louder yeah can you
please come down the stairs louder
jump every stair appreciate it
i um yeah so so he's basically saying
that oh there we go the odds are that
we're living in the simulation are low
did you see that one
yeah boom here it is so this this one we
saw this and i was like wow
here listen to this i used to think we
were living in a simulation
and i talked to some colleagues did some
more reading and
now i feel a little better that we're
probably not
the argument for it was you get a real
universe and then people in there get
really smart and they program computers
and they create
worlds and the people in that world
don't know that they're fake
all right and then they evolve and they
develop computers and they create a
world and they create a world and this
goes all
the way down and so there's the real
world and all the worlds that can create
worlds
except the last one which is still
working on it eventually they'll get
there
all right throw a dart chances are
you're going to hit a world that's
simulated
that's us but we don't know how to make
an actual simulated world where
everybody thinks it's real
so either we're the last of those worlds
that's still working on it
or we're the first one which is actually
real
i'm good with it that interesting i love
those
yeah those are my favorites get your
money man and
it stops and i'm hopeful that's so funny
we went for something deep and
philosophical to like a tick-tock trend
but that but that's the world
well that's why it is a simulation yield
to grass tyson put something nice on
that because that was
because my brain checked out and then i
listened to that song and i go oh i love
that
i love it bank yes yeah it is simulation
but look maybe
maybe he is right maybe he's wrong he
doesn't know everything either
no you know this is you know this is the
same guy that
uh no i don't know you know neil
degrasse tyson i got to i
i did an interview with him once a
couple years ago he said it was
he was either going to go to harvard
which he wound up doing and becoming we
became or be a stripper in the bronx
he if you go look at pictures go google
neil degrasse tyson shirtless
stripper in the bronx this guy was
ripped beyond belief so he's either
going to go be
a male stripper and prostitute in the
bronx or
scientists from harvard yeah let me tell
you something he picked the wrong
choice uh you know he is jacked look at
how gorgeous well that's that's what i
wanted to ask you that's what i want to
bring this up do you think
neil degrasse tyson would have been more
famous had he picked stripper in the
bronx 100 percent
100 now he's kind of a he's kind of an
annoying know-it-all scientist guy
right which i like i like him just fine
but like he's got this kind of like well
and i'm teaching you something
but back then if he had changed his life
around he could have been teaching you
something yeah
you know what i mean huh yeah end of the
world he would have been he i think he
would have been way hotter way cooler if
he
because by the way that i think he could
have parlayed into becoming like a movie
star at some point
right now he can't be a movie star now
because he's too science guy but you
could tell all these guys by the way
this is a real i'm making a real point
they all want to be famous they do okay
so it's kind of like politicians where
you're like like aoc and any of these
people that's like they want to be
famous yes
they do they care about politics you
care about the people they want to be
famous they want to be famous yeah they
want to be famous so that's
he wants to be famous too that's why
he's all over the internet if he wasn't
he would just be a quiet scientist like
most of them are
that's what yeah he wants to be famous
because most scientists
should have been a stripper because then
you would have gotten a five-picture
deal from paramount
he would have been he would have been
one of these yeah i had to save one
scientist if you have to save one
scientist
you have to pick one scientist who's
going to save the world galileo would
you go
okay here's the thing would you go i'll
give you four choices scientists
at any moment in time who would you pick
to save the world for scientists here we
go
number one copernicus okay number two
neil degrasse tyson okay number three
bill nye the science guy okay number
four
elon musk who's gonna save the world out
of those four i
want to say bill nye the science guy but
also i know that he also wants to be
famous
right so i'm going to go with copernicus
didn't want to be famous no
but by the way if tick tock was wrong
back then don't you think capernaum
would be doing them
oh my god they all would have that's the
thing is we're judging people right now
and what they're doing today
if social media was alive 200 years ago
george washington would have you know
yeah of course would have been bad news
george washington would have been like
yo i'm on a delaware
like for sure they would have been doing
selfies yeah george why do you think
they wanted people to paint pictures of
them all the time they
they want they wanted adoration and like
those like anytime you see like a
an iconic painting of someone from that
era
they commissioned those things do you
know what to do they want themselves of
course that's why they put it remember
how remember
you you see in in that era that would be
like people have busts of themselves on
the walls
they want that was fame that was
instagram before instagram existed yeah
dude put up a picture of yourself
there's a story i don't know if it's
true or not but there's a story that i
heard
george washington's painting when he was
crossing the delaware like with his leg
up like almighty yeah yeah yeah
really he had had food poisoning he was
sitting in the back of the canoe like
covered up
because he was like diarrhea that's
hilarious when they crossed it they said
because
you know the painting of him crossing
the delaware was was made years after it
actually happened
they were recounting he's like this is
what i was doing crossing down i was
standing on the front of the boat and
and everyone behind me was below me
yeah no that's not true that's not true
he was in the back just shivering
he's like the boat is rocking too much
fellas yeah and they're like oh shut up
shut up you know we're
we're we're all gonna die yeah and you
get to live and be on the front of the
boat
by the way you know his foot is up how
funny if his foot would fall if he
slipped his teeth fell out
his wig falls august the wind comes and
blows his wig off
his wig is gone and you see this wooden
teeth all over the boat they're picking
up wooden teeth putting them in one by
one yeah
well yeah nothing was as beautiful as
you think it is i've talked about this
on another podcast
but never on hey babe but you know in
like even the revolutionary war with
george washington
they were all but done they were going
to die the whole the whole thing was
going to get destroyed and then a bad
storm came in
in new york in august of 1776
and they were able to escape so if it
wasn't for like a legitimate
thunderstorm
they would have just had the british
would have had all the entire army
rounded up
so it's just literally a rainstorm what
is this teaching save the country
british are afraid of weather yes and
they live in bad weather but they're
scared of thunderclaps because they
didn't want to be like roy in the park
yes and get zapped seven times and it
teaches you that
maybe the weather is being controlled
not saying by who but maybe it is being
controlled and
by maybe we talked about it yesterday
who's controlling the weather
byron allen byron allen comedian from
comics unleashed comics unleashed he
bought the weather channel
look this up he purchased the weather
channel yeah i don't know i don't know
what he bought it for
but when mitzi died at the comedy store
and they did like the
and they did like the memorial people
were talking about he had just bought
like the weather he had just a 12
million dollars in 2018.
i'm looking for a guilt-free cereal
magic spoon
sorry so sorry no
i won't even talk about it anymore okay
but does that protein yes
it has about 13 to 14 grams of protein
okay but then there's probably sugar no
there's no sugar
zero yeah what else do you want to know
carbs four net look it up
how many calories hundred hundred and
thirty hundred and forty 140 140 you're
a machine
flavors chocolate frosted
fruity peanut butter wow come on
because he was he yeah that's i mean
listen to me
we grew up on cereal we know now
things like cigarettes and cereal are
not really that good for you
right but this cereal is come on you
can't have a product called magic spoon
and not be bomb ass
wait a second hold on hold on wait a
second first of all i know if i go to
magicspoon.com hey babe and put in the
promo code hey babe
i'll get five dollars off that's my
mouth that's it's true
but you know what this product does
comes with a hundred percent happiness
guarantee
my you can get your happiness to a
hundred percent if you just go to
magicspoon.com hey bay promo code hey
babe
i mean what company is offering a
hundred percent happiness guarantee who
runs this company the smurfs the smurfs
magical 100 happiness guarantee pimp you
what's your favorite flavor you have
magic spoon
that peanut butter is the best peanut
butter bomb all right magicspoon.com
heybay promo code hey babe these are one
of these ads that it literally just
sells itself because it's so good and
it's good for you
you get money off you buy it if you
don't like it you tell them that you
don't like it
all the money you gave them they give
back to you that's what it is and you
get 100
guaranteed happiness i'm sad give me
magic spoon that's right
byron allen if you don't know did a show
called comics unleash that everybody's
done did you ever do an episode of
comics unless
absolutely not not i got offered i said
no bueno and
this i had nothing this was 2059 nothing
and i still said
no because everyone who knows it in the
comic world we joke about it but it was
like this you're a comic on the shawn
byron allen he's sweet guy very nice guy
but he would do this all the time you
know this was the entire show be like
what's up you guys great to be back here
chris i heard you scared of fish
that's how he would set up a joke and
you're like that's the most it was
basically like
what carson would do or whatever late
night host would do he just would cut to
the punch
he like didn't want to do small talk and
all this stuff in his mind he was like
how can i just make this show as fast as
i can to just get to the joke get to the
job
which to award him a little bit from a
comedian's perspective
it was great because it was just like
bang bang bang bang bang everyone got
their jokes in
right versus sometimes when you're on a
couch on a tv you don't get enough jokes
and because there's too much
going on you know jimmy fallon wants to
toss you know do ring
toss and and and dunk somebody so it's
like
at least back at least with byron the
one thing i'll give him credit for is
that show was successful because it was
like
comic joke comic book comic joke
commercial comic yeah it was smart but
the setups were tough because it was
like so on the nose he's like you know
chris you go up in a bad neighborhood
and i heard uh i heard you had a little
bit of trouble with baseball bats
and you have to give them this cornball
you know what's the hardest part of that
show if you guys go back if you haven't
seen it go back and
watch it on youtube comics unleashed
it's probably still on the air oh he's
probably still is on the air i mean he's
guys he's buying the weather channel
he bought no he bought it 300 million so
but but the what's
the big uncomfortable thing is the is
the other comedians being forced to
laugh
at the other con like [ __ ] you have to
now yeah whether the bit is funny or not
you have
you better let you can't because really
what we'd like to do
is as comics is just like you do the bit
and not laugh because that would be
funnier for us if you're like bombing in
front of you
it was what used to happen on on colin's
show you know tough crowd
you'd get this out of a couple of
comments they go
you know you'd get one of those you
wouldn't get like a real audible laugh
you know other comics if it was a good
joke if the trees clapped on somebody
yeah it would get a good laugh but most
of the time if it was a joke on there
people would be like hey yeah
yeah yeah because we knew what was they
all know what's coming i was gonna say
the main difference was
is byron allen would get you know get
it's all obviously jokes you're doing
bits
tough crowd what was so beautiful about
it it was all off the cuff
so it's just like doing a podcast on a
radio show except for
the greatest clip of all time which is
greg geraldo going at it with uh
dennis lee leary yeah the greatest club
of all time that he's like dennis
leary's mad because
geraldo's just snapping on him he was
snapped on him like three times and
and he's like this guy he's like
bringing jokes to this thing and then
geraldo calmly goes that's what we're
doing here dennis
[Laughter]
it was just like the great it was like
oh my god dude it's like watching one of
those first-person shooter games when
they kill them and then they revive and
they kill him right away again
it was incredible i was like oh dude
well also because i always thought
dennis leary had this smugness about him
and geraldo was like
a hero of mine in comedy he was
genuinely one of my top he's a comics
comic
he was just it was just i just thought
he was fascinatingly quick
so when i saw him do that that made me
just fall in love i was like oh my god i
want to kiss this guy in the mouth
yeah and anyway half your fans don't
even know who that is that's so funny i
think they would no agree
no definitely not but yeah you have a
question
um we talked about ghosts in the last
episode you believe in ghosts any ghost
story
yes i do believe in ghosts of course i
believe in ghosts if you if you hadn't
had one ghost experience i don't think
you're human
i've never had one go i've never had a
ghost you've never had well
i don't even know the right wording but
like an experience with an apparition a
ghost a
a supernatural the unknown like you
can't explain it like what's one that
you've had
my buddy tyler hit the when i growing up
i used to sleep over this house all the
time because we were good
smoking was that nobody's andrew it's
time to be honest with you
when you just play mini flutes oh mini
flutes okay so we play many flutes all
night and uh
no but his house the people that the oh
the people that his mother bought the
house from they died in the home this
old couple natural causes in the home
natural causes wasn't a murder suicide
they killed each other
at 98 years old imagine that 99 years
she said you'll never make it to a
hundred you won't either but
no so what happened was i used to sleep
in the basement all the time and
and um upstairs was a the kitchen had
two galley doors you know galley doors
that hide inside of the walls
and galley doors you couldn't close them
quietly if you tried everyone that has
one in their home knows or you ever grew
up with one they're like
they're so loud right they're coming out
of the wall so i'm sleeping downstairs
and i couldn't sleep i was tossing and
turning and the house always did have
this like very ominous vibe it was like
tucked into the woods
just always felt just very dark and
shady and and you can't really see
anybody around you
and so i'm i can't toss and turn and i
can't go to sleep
and i hear the gallery door to the
kitchen so i think oh
ty's mom must be awake like me like
maybe she's going to get a late night
snack and i was like i'll get some food
cause i'm up and i'm hungry and i
couldn't sleep
so i walk upstairs and the doors are all
closed
and i was like it was seconds it could
that's impossible
right like it literally couldn't have
happened there's just no way so
i go in there and i'm like whatever i
get in the kitchen i grab like a
you know like a candy bar i go back
downstairs i'm eating i hear it again
and it's distinct you know it when you
know what it is it's not like it could
have been something i know what that
sound is
i have one in my house now i hear it
again and i immediately put the candy
bar down
and i'm like mom because i would call
his mom mom i was like mom
nothing mom i walk upstairs we'll
explore that later after the story
i call her i call her mommy i call her
mommy no
i walk upstairs again and the doors are
all still closed
and i swear to god on my life i was
freezing cold
right i felt ice cold and i get i'm sure
that's just anxiety it's all in my mind
freezing cold oh dude it i was freezing
it was freezing cold
and i was like and i wanted someone to
wrap me up
but but i swear to god i felt so it felt
just so ominous that it was like
someone was toying with me it could have
been his mother because her room to get
back to her room
she could have never made it there all
the way down the back hallway right
without me seeing her because i walked
right upstairs afterwards
so i was freezing cold and i went
downstairs and the rest of the night i
just stared
at the stairwell and all i was waiting
for was to see something or feel
something
but i just couldn't sleep my brain was
just staring at this um and it just
felt so like something was happening but
i just couldn't go back up there then so
do you believe that it was like i didn't
see anything but the feeling was
disgusting i couldn't even tell you what
it was but do you believe but
okay so let me two questions one i
didn't know that redheads could get
called we can't which is that's why it's
a ghost
crazy two do you believe they say when
you feel really cold it's because it
cause it because it goes let's one go
and their farts are cold and is that
really what it is
yeah that's why when you know when
someone goes it feels cold in here
because ghosts like
and the fart enrafts you yeah wraps in a
cold fart and a cold fart but
let me ask you do you think how childish
it was your
welcome to hey babe yeah is this did you
think that your
brain was making all of course or do you
think that there actually was like a rip
in a dim because it's made him thinks
ghosts are rips
in dimensions it's not spirits coming
back to you it's dimensions
i think see i think our brain is so
powerful like we talked about before
with cracking your head and speak in
spanish yes
that we can literally physically
manifest those things
we use energy that exists in the world
all of us have energy your heart's
beating right now just
there's electromagnetic pulses in your
body who's what's charging it you don't
plug in at night it just goes until it's
done
i don't anymore then what after the
vaccine i don't need to plug in no plug
in anymore i'm charged up baby
so think about that you have electro
electromagnetic force in your body
that's just happening just because it is
there is no explanation for it there's
no reasoning for it other than the fact
that it's
this is the miracle of life right so
when you die i believe heavily that that
this energy does go somewhere into the
world that's what reincarnation in my
mind is
so it goes into these spaces that that
live in between us and you have the
ability to manifest these using your
electric forces of your mind
and make something obvious look at the
human body our cells are specialized to
conduct
electrical currents the elements of our
body sodium potassium calcium and
magnesium have an electrical charge
so when we die i don't believe those
charges disappear i believe they get
pushed into the universe and they get
pulled into other things
do you think elon musk is potentially
taking the energy and that's what's
fueling the tesla 100 an alien
that's what it's so we're saying it here
on this show he kisses every tesla
before it goes out are you serious
that's how he charges it for the first
time
yeah he's exhausted so we have said on
the show we have cracked the code that
tesla
is charged by the electro
electromagnetic energy of dead people
100 percent
that's it 100 that's it keep on dying in
america
i believe this i know this sounds kind
of kooky but i believe we manif our
brain is so
unbe what percentage of our brain do we
use again it's something remarkable
unless you're david blaine which i have
a crazy story about him what is he
eleven he's got he's
he's gonna be yeah he's 11 or 12. so
look at this i mean look at this just
take this for an example
if you use only 10 of your brain i mean
truly truly
so you're telling me that much real
estate is left alone
just to be left alone it's just it's
waiting to be now listen
listen here's the thing um what i'm
going to tell you is
is that we have a study that debunked
the myth that humans use only 10 of the
brain it was
from pinterest studies though so this
study was designed was done by pinterest
by by people so sewing stuff and making
stuff at home to sell out of their
garage
but i don't know they say they say that
if we talk about brain stuff they say
the average power consumption of a
typical adult
is 100 watts and the brain consumes 20
percent of this making the power of the
brain
20 watts so here so here's the deal
let's just say we use 20 of our brain
okay weight that's like using 20 of this
house right it's two rooms
yeah so what's in the other rooms what
about your phone when your phone's at
twenty percent it starts to make
you know it starts to go in low power
mode low power mode so we're on low
power mode we are in low power mode
right now
how do you get fully charged a kiss from
elon musk a kiss from elon musk
on the lips yeah so you think that
actually maybe extraterrestrials or
interdimensional beings are just to have
their brains
they're humans with their brains
probably 100 percent in fact
i don't even i don't think that i think
there's comically i think there's some
aliens that are like 65 percent and they
get made fun of by the 80 percenters
and they all make fun of us right they
all make fun of us but like the 80s are
like oh
the 60s are going down again and they're
going down on like a wednesday evening
you know
like when you when we when when you know
like the the the pentagon just released
footage saying
yeah this is a ufo remember when we were
kids they're like come on
it's not you now finally they're like
yeah it was a ufo
yeah of course it's so funny they
admitted but i think those are like the
65 percenters the guys that we see all
the time
you know 65 the guy the 80 percenters
they know how to come in and get out
without us even noticing so i was going
to say so you think that if we ever do
see an
alien if we ever do see aliens on this
planet earth it would most likely be
a low percentage will most likely be a a
those aliens extraterrestrials are on a
school trip they're special needs aliens
on a school trip yes that we're seeing
them that it's basically their short bus
version
it's who we see as the high intelligent
beings in fact interesting and they get
knocked by the uber intelligent aliens
the uber gets mocked all the time which
by the way stop alien hate
because i know that this is a big issue
that's going on up there right now is
these above aliens they always make fun
of the 65s
yeah and it's disgusting they say that
you ride you ride the tiny saucer down
there don't you
yeah don't you take the short saucer
down to earth and they're like we sure
do what's wrong with that and they're
like
all right all right yeah it's it's
enough of this yeah it's enough
to allow aliens to identify as
extraterrestrials and interventional
beings
as they choose i'm just tired i'm just
tired of the judgment
most of it man i'm tired of almost all
of it by the way well they're saying
that
uh uh alberta rcmp 911 dispatchers
fielding calls about okay
so so basically what's this is insane so
what's been happening lately and this is
this just happened
the other day yeah is is um a beam of
lights
we're in the sky over was it florida i
believe it was florida
florida it wasn't florida no no that's
that's in that's edmonton that's canada
no but that the edmonton uh uh
uh press or whatever this is the article
but you know what those lights were
they were saying it was from the uh um
spacex launch so spacex
has been doing a lot of this one though
this one
but here's my here's here's what i think
though
is that even these aliens that you're
seeing right now or extraterrestrials
i still believe that it's other
countries governments that have
extraterrestrial power
but are just reverse engineering bob
lazar you ever watched all those
yes bob lazar documentaries that's what
he believes so bob
what other countries dude because name a
country that you think it is
well what argentina
versus argentina argentina and brazil
brazil
is from sao paulo to the sky you know
i don't i think i think legitimately
when we see
when we see um a ufo coming to our orbit
i think it's on accident
right like i think they're not coming
here and they literally get into our
orbit and they're like
whoa this is so lame this is done we got
to get out of here well could there be a
thing where even people there's even
people in this world who are above
countries like there's there is a a
global world order you're talking about
the you're talking about the
countries don't really exist like they
exist tonight us what's it called the
illuminati is what you're talking about
yeah the highest group of be no this
sounds like an alex jones podcast at
some point
you know the illuminati they got you
dude they're on their money
yeah should now should alex jones cohost
hey babe yes or no oh my god
i think you should go i think you should
take over jeopardy that's what i was
thinking
you know how fun that would be did you
imagine alex jones did an episode of
jeopardy
yeah how funny would that be things that
are gay for 100
yeah everything frogs like
everything his conspiracy theories are
just absolutely like
like they're so far gone that you're
like i know you don't believe those
right conspiracy theories to some degree
you're like i get him i get him his are
so
absurdist that you're like i know you
don't believe that listen you know what
that you're just saying that to you
you're that's like kathy griffin it's
like you're saying it because you want
people to get angry about it you know we
wanted to ask you too because you know
us being from new york and you
being in la we've i've been here for two
months i can't find a bodega it what's
the la version of a bodega is there
anywhere where i can see a cat
and get you know a beer and a ham
sandwich and a cart
you know a phone card to call home to
puerto rico no because of our health and
safety standards here in los angeles
they don't allow it yeah they won't
allow
so you've never seen in la there's no
cats in the stores
no i mean we're just not you know new
york has a special place for that kind
of stuff we don't have anything like
that do we have
we have like um the closest thing we
would have would be like you know mom
and pop corner stores that would sell
stuff or like the old like
just an old pharmacy in a neighborhood
but we don't we don't have that beauty
of a bodega where it's like ham sandwich
um
you know or a can of oil for your car in
chicago you can't
chicago has all that stuff but not to
the degree that new york does right
new york is the king of that stuff like
yeah chicago has neighborhood corner
stores
but new york is the you guys that's the
burgeoning capital of like
a bodega a hangout which is also a drug
spot which is also a mafia hideout which
is also like
where you get your tarot cards done you
know what i mean like it's everything in
one
right we don't really have that that's
like you guys bodegas are like walmart
for the miscellaneous yes
but we don't have anything like that we
should we really i wish we had some
more culture the cultural things that we
have here are like taco
taco shops right like east l.a taco
trucks and taco shops and
what they do is they park taco trucks in
gas station parking lots they make deals
with the gas station
yeah the those are those go get those so
it's nice to have a little unleaded
gasoline on the avocado
well they do say that the smell of 90
it's 89 and 93
intensifies the cilantro i believe it so
if once it gets the fumes to get in your
nostrils let me ask you questions
what's a better smell than gasoline is
it the best do you like gasoline i love
this i love it why is that not a cologne
does do you like it pop like the smell
of gasoline dad
yeah everybody's so funny some people
hate it no dude
should we make two questions should we
make a gasoline cologne and or candle
second question should you and i open up
the first bodega in los angeles i would
absolutely love it pimp what do you say
let's do it oh my god pimp chrissy d and
andy pandys gasoline and yeah
gasoline emporium and bodega yeah and
salvagano of course we need we need his
money to invest
we need someone to buy the whole thing
we need someone to buy the building yeah
we need someone to purchase the property
and keep up and be a responsible adult
now there's one thing we we notice about
la all the people here believe in the
signs heavy
they're always talking about women
everybody talks about the signs what do
you mean like
you know oh astrological corn or are you
a libra
do you have any any belief in that
anything
i don't care about that are you sure if
it makes who's ever talking to me about
that go away do you know what i mean
when someone's like don't you believe in
signs and i'm like yes yeah just so we
don't have to talk about it a lot well i
got to be honest if i say no they're
going to try to convince you for the
next hour and a half
so if i just say yes it's kind of like q
anon it is
it's actually q so here we've said it
here first on hey babe andrew and i've
cracked many codes today
but the one if you are asking for signs
or someone who is
involved with signs whether it be your
your granny to
you know your your your uncle who's a
broadway actor you are in q anon and
that
and we've blown your cover yeah if you
come up to you we know what you're doing
and say what's your sign i'm big into
astrological science what you're really
saying is
q q by the way this is how you hand and
honestly i have friends that believe in
and all that stuff but like the best way
if you don't
know someone you know they bring it up
to you like let's pretend you're really
into it okay so
ask me ask me if i'm into it in the same
enthusiasm that they usually would go
ahead
q and on are the sign no just sign
people which we've decoded is the same
thing can i ask you a question yeah
what's up what's your birthday
october october so you must be a taurus
because
a libra a libra end of october can i
tell you something about signs yeah
do i believe in them i believe them more
than anything do you have about an hour
and a half to sit down and chat about it
no you've got somewhere to go you see i
flipped it on you yeah
you came to me with the energy let me
tell you about your sign and i'm like
let me tell you about what's really
going on in my life
i bring up all the depths of the sadness
and the scariness and the troubles that
i'm going through yeah
you're gone out of here you might not
even believe in signs that you might
de-join q
you might unjoin q from that yeah but
guess what job done how about you and i
create something miyu and sal
create something called there's q and
hon but why don't we do
cute cuteness
just cute boys being cute around the
world it's just the three of us being
cute cute cute
talking about puppies and and and little
cats and
fun little outfits for animals yeah a
little oh my and someone comes upstairs
and they say
are you are you a capricorn and you go
have you ever thought about putting
little ears on your cat
yes he already has yours it's like but a
second pair is even cuter
so welcome to queue tonight we go around
all the zoos at night we open the gates
we release
the animals animals and by the way that
was us if we want to not joke around
anymore what happened in chicago was
cute and on yes that was our first
we wanted everyone to play with a bear
cute out and and
disclosure let's because the people are
wondering and the reason why sal isn't
here
this weekend we need you is because sal
is unfortunately in prison because of
that stunt
so he's in prison because jail jail jail
sorry but he may go to prison if we
don't beat this case yeah we don't beat
this case and and he
obviously sal's got great lawyers i mean
you know we're doing all we can for him
but he listen he told us hey i'm the as
the leader of cudanan yes
well i told him as the leader of cuda9
somebody's going to fall for this
it's you it's you and i said as the
other leader of cudanan yeah chris and i
of course will take out the manual labor
part of it yeah but you've got to be the
you know the brain behind behind all
this bronze
yeah because sal said sal was like he
was like listen i
i'll take the fall he's like because no
nobody cares about me he was like you
know i don't
know i'm not on tv i don't do anything
right i don't you know you guys are the
stars correct
he's like but i nobody needs me it's
like i don't have a show correct he's
like i don't even have any friends he's
like all my friends are a bunch of
jokers and i don't need them
and by the way not practical at all this
whole thing was not practical so he said
if anyone's gonna be in prison let it be
me so you guys can continue to shine
and do what you need to do god bless you
sally and thank you for doing that thank
you so much for for doing that for the q
and on crew yeah we will get you out as
soon as we can rig it out of money
we'll raise enough money uh christy d
patreon uh
that's one way to donate to the patreon
if you really want to get sal
out of jail go to patreon.com
that's the best way that we're gonna get
sal out of jail if of course you want
him back with the cue to non-crew
whatever you want
now here's the thing is um we're gonna
close here but here's the thing
is and then we'll just by the way before
we do this i want you to tell everyone
first of all i want to say thank you so
much thank you for for coming in and on
hey babe you're
fantastic excellent the fans are going
to love this where can the peeps see you
go to andrew santo.com that's where all
my tickets are i'm touring right now i'm
doing
can we announce the big one that you
told me yesterday
it's not but i'm doing uh i'm doing
atlantic city
i'm doing boston i'm doing madison i'm
doing nashville i'm doing
houston i'm doing and we're adding dates
right now and both of us are adding a
bunch of dates because i saw your i saw
what you got offered i saw
we've got offers coming we've got i
sound like trump we've got offers coming
they're coming he's always giving you
like what's going to come so is it going
to turn its way
yes because that way you can avoid it if
it doesn't come up but yes we have stuff
coming up just go to andrewsantina.com
and then you can watch bad friends and
whiskey ginger both on youtube or
podcast
wherever they must be that's where
that's uh that's that's where it is
where tickets are
i love it i love it and for me
chrisdcomedy.com
got a bunch of dates coming up big one
just announced october 23rd the fox
theater
foxwoods in connecticut
so christy comedy.com got all the
tickets up there now
uh in again thank you so much for coming
on course we
though and i'm just gonna say this and
then you do what you made with it
you came on uh uh uh uh we sent you
hey babe sal and i sent you a bag of poo
poo
elephant poopoo to the studio okay then
you
sent back to us tied me to a chair and
you put yours and bobby lee's pubic hair
right now sorry dad correct that she put
it in so now
we have another thing coming back to you
and i'm just gonna say
what it is and i'm not gonna explain it
just know that
it's four words that's gonna be a
nightmare for you tt
jerry's folgers can oh my god
goodbye
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey babe
hey babe hey